hey guys it's Eric this is not a live
stream this is a video just for YouTube
I am beginning a tournament today so st.
Louis North Congress I have the web page
here if people want to check it out it's
us chess champ comm will click on norm
Congress and all the players and the
pairings have been determined they were
actually posted a few weeks ago so if we
go to pairings I'm playing in the item
section and in just a few hours I'll be
playing FM Aaron Jacobsen someone I've
never played before but someone I've
been preparing for for last few weeks so
I think what I'll do in this video is
sure a little bit of my preparation and
I won't be posting this video until
after the tournament ends most likely
and I'm planning to do a series of
videos of both preparing for opponents
and then the postgame recap so hopefully
this will be interesting for for viewers
and it'll be interesting for me to never
actually really done something quite
like this especially during a tournament
so I have a PGN file of my my prep for
various opponents this is not complete
so as the term in goes on I'll be
probably recording myself making some of
these these prop files which I have here
but we're gonna open up prep for Aaron
and I've already determined kind of the
line that all I want to aim for maybe I
can show if we go back to the other view
there's a website that I use called
chess abc.com it's a relatively new site
I believe and it's something which is
just a great tool for preparation
especially against high level players so
what I did initially was I typed in my
once named Jacobson I can type correctly
and then Aaron actually has a brother
Brandon who's also playing the
tournament but the other section so I
won't have to worry about Brandon and
the great thing about the site is you
can not only access a player's games in
the database but you can can basically
view their opening tree
so if I click prepare against black I
can see like all the moves he's
encountered in tournament play in in
recent years and I've determined that I
want to play c4 and the reason for this
is that against d4 he's actually an Enzo
player from what I saw after a six
Knight c3 he had one game in the nihms
oh and 2018 so this is kind of what I'm
basing my preparation off of and I don't
want to allow specifically in the MS o
Indian so by starting with c4 if he
tries to get in him so let's say e six
Knight c3 and let's say he plays Knight
f6 here I'll play e4 and it's a
completely different variation known as
the floormat kind of variation so if we
switch back to chess base I already have
basically my my prop mapped out so I
think this video will just be like going
through the prep maybe adding some
things just doing a quick overview the
game does start in just over three hours
so I want to just relax beforehand
probably take a run or walk just around
outside get some fresh air
I think that's that might be more
valuable than just crowning lines into
my mines right before anyway e6 rc4 move
one I'm most expecting a six I also
found this chest calm account so I was
looking at some of these chests con
games he's capable of playing a lot of
things he fives a
a possibility if he does play e5 I'm
gonna play e3 which it's a move I've
actually never played before but it's an
attempt to perhaps get him out of his
comfort zone
and I'm a time on of Sicilian players
black so this is essentially timeline
with a tempo if you were to play most
naturally I play naturally and then
there's a few lines here there's Bishop
before I play 90 to see 683 so that
possible variation probably Bishop c7
should be to solid position nothing to
complain about
I would not imagine he played defy and
it's just down a tempo in a variation
which I I'd like to play as black so
guess a move is c6 here well then I
would play d4 and it takes I probably
take with Queen and it's a a reverse
I'll open up a tempo so I don't think
there's much to look a look at further
and I don't think this is most likely
anyway so we'll focus on e6 Knight c3
and now I I would imagine he'll play d5
I mean if he plays one of six anything
goes into the floor McKenna's I'll be
relatively happy d5 takes takes e5 this
is all main line in d4 and there's a
game that I'm following between Nakamura
and Leslie so from the 2015 millionare
open it was very nice game Nakamura just
crushed so turn eight c6 Bishop b5
should know of knight c6 is probably not
the most popular move there's also a
Bishop to b4 here it should be for Queen
a for check and Bishop b5 it's a nice
variation and then yeah taking on c3
doesn't really quite work out for for
black because there's pressure on c6
57 Bishop d7 I did not add this move to
my file earlier I did not check this
with stockfish so see if I can come up
with the right move here I'd assume this
Bishop takes c6 Bishop takes c3 B takes
c3 Bishop takes c6 Queen c2 well maybe
just 92 probably just 92 here
very solid defend everything yeah
smoked fish lady too and they g2 and the
Sauk fish give us like plus equals is it
plus equal plus equal okay
so 2x takes Bishop e7 castle castle
yeah like later on there's ideas of like
93 f4 f5 this is actually what kind of
happened in the Binaca so gain we go
after a knight c6 still Bishop e5 so I
guess this could transpose yeah let me
say transposes something right okay
Bishop e7 was playing and yeah I really
like the way knock I played this just
like very simple developing and black
had to do something plain a 5 and then
yeah starting wasn't I takes e4 I think
a lot of things came with tempo Bishop
d3 was slightly surprising but it makes
sense because after you get the
structure that pong gets rolling I'm a
little bit curious if black plays f6
here
and sometimes this is what I like to do
in preparation like play a move
I haven't analyzed and try and figure
out myself and then then check stockfish
so at 6:00 there's a four there's also
just taking her in the way my Chi 3 so
Knight takes e4 Bishop takes e4 Knight
g3 off takes e5 takes you for takes d4
oh it's a little bit messy maybe just
takes me for Bishop takes me for a three
as she moves back at four but she moves
back to you for a knight g35 all right
let's check sawfish I would probably
take and play off three don't spend too
much time on this okay so it looks
ninety sixty four and three is up there
Bishop c6 so like c1 ok stockfish is
already giving a pretty nice plus for
whites this point it's just about
playing something where ideas like very
clear so I'm looking at the lawn f3
Bishop a5 f4
yes I I like this f3 there's about five
four we're ready to take on c6 and play
rook c1 also 93 ideas looks very
pleasant for the lights
if takes we take the D pawn this is a
target this is potential square okay
fair enough
yeah for this for the purpose of this
video I'm not going to show like the
full Nakamura so game but if people want
to check it out it's just Google
Nakamura so 2015 shouldn't be too hard
to find this game because I am kind of
on sometimes constraints and again I
don't think floor McKenna's is the most
likely I think we're most likely to get
this position after moved to I'll play
d4 so we go into Queens gambit declined
and then yeah let me go back actually to
[Music]
this cuz I forget if he's had so you
have this position so d4 906 c4 e6
Knight c3 so he's played e5 once this
was back in 2015 and they went into one
of these lines
maybe I should look at but take a quick
glance at a six I move through because
this is something which has been trendy
lately which he might try and use as a
surprise
I'll stay focused on 906 so I've done
some preparation here I'm planning to go
into Queens gambit declined exchange
variation after taking on d5 expect to
eat xt5 this should be five c63 and now
one of the main lines is Bishop f5 which
he's capable of flying I think I saw
like one or two chests comm games in I
think he's most likely to play Bishop e7
which is why I have kind of this is a
main line I wrote to do earlier because
I I didn't add more analysis after this
okay this is me mine at least for him if
we just touch on Bishop f5 this is a
long I play as black so I have some
experience with these positions queen a3
Bishop c6 takes six six six and we get
this queenless middle game black has a
bishop error if it also has a damaged
pawn structure and there's a nice really
nice scheme between Carlson and Kramnik
from it was a twenty twenty sixteen or
Carlsen just completely wiped kramnik
off the board and started with Knight f3
and I'm actually gonna put it in
training mode oh no wait what is this a
new feature in chess base
this is a new feature in chess face I've
never seen before
okay well I guess know what this diagram
signifies I guess I have to make the
move and it will continue making moves
after ninety seven I believe that each
[ __ ] a move yeah Bishop e7 is what
Kramnik played and Carlsen played this
very interesting with 92 I want to say
so I'm in the situation where I have to
I have to play like Carlsen I deal with
92 is to go to g3 and it's at five what
do I play it right away I think I do not
worried about Bishop before like this
should be for King d1 and I looked at
this a few days ago
I'm so so sorry Paul I think oh yeah the
move is actually very nice here Knight
f5 f5 they takes b2 and then King c2 if
not a fork in B 3 of 9 c4 takes takes
and rook either up to be one should be
good tonight GF v q g7
yeah the king c2 here yeah this is where
I'm not actually sure could be b3 King
see - there's issues on the C file
remember Carlsen me that looks so easy
well maybe it's just for p1 yeah Rick b1
was like such a simple move there's a g4
Bishop d3 Ellie Bishop d3
and now g4 yeah g4 has a nice
multi-purpose idea reinforcing the night
and preparing that g2 wait what
oh it's keee - okay I'm gonna go out of
this mode because that was weird
I remembered the most I think the most
important things so why not chief for
right away
I'm not seeing anything like so concrete
so for some reason it likes kini two
more well maybe because like some in
some cases wants to play g3 to Bishop
f8g fort now okay yeah this is a very
nice nice flow for lights yeah again if
you if you guys want to see the full
game just google its Carlsen kramnik
Queen's Gambit exchange or Queens gambit
declined exchange 2016 or just Stavanger
2016 so one more variation as Bishop d7
it's hard to like calculator to to say
the exact likelihood of each variation
happening but based on what I saw at
least chess calm and his tournament
games I think this is most likely Bishop
d3 so we go into one of these kind of
standard structures I would play Knight
f3 and then very important move here to
play h3 and again this is something I
play as black and this line h3 has kind
of given me the most headings with idea
that black wants to play Knight g6 and
prevent Bishop f4 and then try and win
the bishop here but here I can play
Bishop f4 right away just preserving the
bishop and then even though these
Knights look nice they're used as kind
of fuel for a White's eventual pawn
storm why it ends up castling queenside
and then storming on the King side
gaining tempo on the Knights so the main
line here is Bishop d6
takes takes castling and then it turns
into a very
short game I did paste in a couple
example games one with with tray of drea
was actually the person who I I learned
this from just by looking through his
game as many years ago this h3 idea yeah
I need me maybe this game seemed very
easy lisa attack at some point I think
he left the damage slip okay this is
just a crushing position so I'm not
really scared of getting into this I
think positions it's comfortable to play
so I want to look at maybe one line
maybe 94 here I think I looked at 94
look at scores very well for for a white
Bishop takes me for do you take c4 oh
wait is this oh this is Carlsen van
wailing oh this is a line that I played
in the past is black I forgot scrap this
comes from this exact variation my game
is probably in here somewhere
yeah there I am I somehow won even
though I was losing yeah 94 I should
look at I don't think he's like so
booked up to play something like this
but it's perhaps a dangerous move I
remember looking at it and finding like
all these interesting ideas for for
black maybe I just played Bishop f4 it's
a pawn sacrifice there's an amazing game
Vaughn Whaley Carlsen where Carlsen one
is black
the engine does not like grabbing upon
interesting likes taking and castling
that seems so timid
but let's look into it because again I
just want something simple castling so I
guess I have ideas of taking e4 mm okay
computer change its mind let's look at
Bishop f4 kind of like Bishop f4 Oh are
there ideas of Knight takes d5 here and
block probably won't allow it
wait i five Knight takes d5 she takes
oh there's Bishop b4 check in the queen
escapes never mind
close this so let's look at night d f6
actually let's reopen stockfish just got
some quick recommendation castling i was
imagine Bishop d6 at some points
nyeeehhh - interesting
yeah very positional there should be six
I mean at some point might wants to go
for some I nor the attack I mean I D I'd
be okay playing this your says equal
look at ninety five to score as well for
whites
very confusing position most people play
g6 or Queens let's look at Queen c7 92
threatening f3 it looks like okay I'm
not going to spend too much time on this
because this is not a likely variation I
get to this position before I think I'll
just play it about 4/5 stay solid
castling looks looks very solid
okay so I think I actually covered like
most of the prep file yeah I'm not like
hundred percent sure what exact line to
expect but I've I think I've covered the
bases looked at English with 'if I've
looked at Queens gambit declined
exchange variation with the floor
McKenna's so I'm gonna I'm gonna wrap
things up here hopefully people found
this interesting I mean this is kind of
the process I take in preparing for
people at least reviewing a preparation
file for later games if I do have the
time beforehand I'll hopefully get a
chance to to record myself making the
initial file and doing more of going
through there there are terming games
and online games so okay the run starts
in two hours and 49 minutes I'm gonna
take a walk and I'll see you guys in the
future
goodbye oh also look at the video
description I'll have links to all this
stuff
alright spy